ok next one plane on the exact same
auckland some of the game before try to
transpose to a French ok it doesn't want
it advanced variation so we got some
isolated pawn line ok this is friendly
he took to conceive five with autumn
waiting for me to spend a move there and
I also got the bishop on the knight on
f6 which is some quite some achievement
usually in this kind of position of
white play some exactly there you you
don't get to get this came we might try
Bishop e3 at some point
want to play 90 forward his cut we
should be three then
mmm not sure
came down waiting okay maybe is planning
a 23 preparing nada form
don't have a good square for this bishop
this is some this is annoying you know
this is really a half move but you to
try to connect rook somehow okay prevent
some NightA c sub queen to c7
so I don't like my position looks very
uncomfortable somewhat strange I don't
know what what was my mistake there
because I it's early dc5 some not a good
good way to play no idea no idea what
went wrong there this is just just
better for Wyatt
try to play Bishop f5 maybe put the Sun
on g6
generally speaking I don't want to
accept change too much with me turn to
connect the rooks and protective eight
of it here ok at least I don't have the
isolated porn anymore don't think this
was so the best way to play at least
that would be surprised maybe he's got
to know some discoveries he on the
bishop the bishop is not protected now
830 ice age three not hanging what's the
big trick don't see it
maybe this was the most lib or something
no idea what is he I have anything
special now don't see it nope nothing
special
ok some exchanges now which I don't mind
of course and i'll try to get the bishop
on d5 this is so uncomfortable pin ok
but now this one now it's hard for him
to move okay can just take chief chief
of corset maybe I've got something
better even it it looks like there might
be something ok let's play it simple so
just two extra pawns for nothing ok time
warning check yes he's got two bishops
but good everything nicely coordinated
g5 Bishop just covers everything and he
still got some weaknesses yeah this also
won't help don't think so maybe I should
have prevented it but it's just too much
because it's got some further weaknesses
on f3 and all these pawns a week check
check
check
check yeah I know it's a wrong colored
bishop check just scratch off game drawn
oh what a game yeah I shouldn't have
gone to the opposite colored bishop Zen
game it's certainly completely winning
but at least it takes some some
precision well no idea even the way this
point in the game should win somehow he
lost MP completely useless of course
well I don't have enough not to analyze
this okay let's try another game